if you're ready to explore the  Commonwealth one last time fallout 4s  final expansion is coming soon I'm Tony  and this is your amusement filled  gamespot news update fallout 4 is nucca  world DLC pack launches on august 30th a  new trailer from bethesda showed off the  areas you'll be exploring in this  amusement park overrun by Raiders  including kitty kingdom and the Galactic  zone you'll be able to lead these Raider  gangs yourself so that should make for  some interesting new quests you can  expect the usual new armor weapons and  enemies to Snuka world is the sixth and  final expansion for Fallout 4 you can  get it by itself for twenty bucks or as  part of the game season pass as for  what's next from Bethesda there hasn't  been much word on an Elder Scroll six or  even a fallout 5 but you can stick with  gamespot to stay up to date for all the  most important video game news y'all  ready in the right place